I was dying to work with him when he
came back and just into town he's a
friend of mine he was one of the first
people that was very coming to me when I
started comedy so he has a special place
in my heart not to mention he's one of
the funniest damn men in this scene
locally but then he went to New York and
just blossomed even more and he's back
and you guys he's clocking in with over
a hundred friends on Facebook I'm glad
they put me out from New York to perform
for Billy's friends but I can't be here
for this video
I mention t-shirts up to this part of
the clan now I finally am part of a way
family's magic cardigans it's great
hi pathways I have an Asian man I have
Asian or in another century of Chinese
I'm from a province in china called
South Korea China and Japan prevalence
is pretty good problems my favorites I
love being Asian cuz I never someone is
racist to me I'm like oh you pay
respectful people a little keep to
themselves okay good I'm finding an
affordable car we're trying really hard
okay we're doing it we're pretty cool
people a lot of people make fun of us
because be dogs some Chinese and maybe
very shocking because in America dogs
are treated like family members but in
Asia we treat our family members like
so we don't think we do it's kind of a
custom where instead of playing an
animal we just look at her grandma make
sure she has a home unless unless of
course she's a baby girl which case we
throw in the river this location people
call agent mothers tiger mom so I don't
like that term because Tigers don't use
kill to catch their prey I'm getting fat
dear the best beer don't do that
a lot of my friends are Asian said they
were so excited about the crazy
regenerations movie that came out that
we haven't been a civilization for 3,000
[ __ ] pants so now where we going down
that we got our own Madea movie so we've
made a real weight a mental accomplice
[ __ ] I'm rocking it
London trains for a change this movie I
love the Black Panther movie that was
also a great racial movie is it against
black kids someone they can look out
and not just someone like one with the
King jr. or now they have a paper that
goes like a cat I'm just jealous but I
going to come out with our superhero
movie okay the Asian Panda live in your
office and leave your furniture we do it
it's hard to date as an anxious man I
don't know if you guys ever like tried
it but first looks great because I feel
like everyone things Asian women are
beautiful but not a lot of people to
Asian men are beautiful which doesn't
even make any sense to pay youth
engagement we're going to create it me
[ __ ] I have a crucial part of the
sense of process please stop trying to
steal me
so it'll be very beautiful but have it
be rain engineers and that's affordable
love the Asian thing oh now my friend it
was like dude I don't know if you know
this but you have a really agent smile
like thanks now I get to think about my
physically different from everyone
around me every time I feel happiness
look forward to I am I'm not racist I
don't understand racism you know I think
people too
I just need to know in the first if
you've over their skin I hate you over
their souls call me buddy gets my levels
and the shoe hater I don't see race I
only smell it when they're waiting in
the back and I'm holding any one buddy
gonna beat on you the Olympics or the
World Cup I think that brings us all
together I think that's great because
the basic other countries that I didn't
even know do each other
Costa Rica Brazil Japan holy [ __ ] what
did they need Mozambique versus Sweden
I don't even know they were the same
universe and the screamin was horrible
what's next the Westeros game the
problem in Star Trek I am NOT a very
racist person but sometimes I am racist
okay it comes up within me like I was on
a plane and it's all I do reading a book
in Arabic and it kind of freaked out but
then I started pull the corner of the
page and put it back in his bag I was
like oh thank god he's got future plans
I'm crazy for some bullets on the middle
of a bug President Richard I think it's
great that we have a lot of different
races here and those other white people
a big part you guys rocking it I just
see it's making a legacy for yourself
I think it's funny that Tanner as a
white person saying you should really it
was my Mexican friend Tanner as a black
man tannest suffix joke really
I think either way Brian is a good thing
but I think a lot of people do it
incorrectly you know people are always
like the Nazis or the Confederate flag
and effort into building a castle or you
only that's not white pride that says
racism you know you have to be wait to
be racist you know I need the juice to
not a white thing I can't let it open to
me I feel like a lot of white men don't
have a lot of personality you know I
feel like they're just like collection
of memories got together with Harry
it was hard today you know a lot of
women don't find me attractive I'm still
single
I'm looking for a soul mate but I get to
be her I mean today maybe it's her
father she needs to get out more for the
loser I do better I am looking for a
smart and intelligent woman because I
want to find a girl who is
intellectually stimulated by the mental
exercise of the fighting attractive
[Music]
I'm gonna play our girls into puzzles
[ __ ] you're worrying that yeah I guess I
can find that attractive
my friends like dude he'll learn how to
talk to girls maybe or maybe girls
should learn how to listen to Hans why
don't want to hear about the Federal
Reserve it affects all of us this girl
was like my vagina is a 3d printer
because I can make a baby and I was like
that's not even accurate your womb is a
3d printer and vagina is the Train
it's not gonna very good 3d picture it
only has one thing watch Harris takes
the nine months of printing the whole
time is printing it's complaining not
see any trace that night but a mailing
moist its own reward that's way I I'm
glad that women give birth
I'm what men don't give birth if we give
birth big like bro I've been eating so
much protein and creatine for my
pregnancy its babies like 27 pounds
ready bro check out my six-pack an
ultrasound I love those jeans in the
first trimester it seems that nothing a
lot of my friends are into working out
you know I when I go to the gym I can
only work out on ways that other people
have it react that way I can tame the
body of an [ __ ]
you know I just want to get strong
enough where if a girl puts her hand on
my chest I don't have to take a step
back a lot of my friends like yeah
you're both smart but I'm street smart
oh you're smart in a way that's not
measurable or comparable like I'm gonna
kick your ass good that's the best place
to kick ahead of the game that kind of
fighting you thinking about my but one
of my friends like dude were so lucky
we're not gay can you imagine if I said
ejaculate were attracted to wasn't
attracted to you back I was like whoa
can't even imagine I'm so different than
us they're the other this try all the
time I don't understand the people who
are like it's Adam and Eve not Adam and
Steve because Adam and Eve were terrible
parents publicly and avaiable they were
they messed up okay they shouldn't be an
example first of all they did something
God and they you know fruit which is 10k
they raised Cain and Abel and Cain
murdered Abel what are they taking
parenting advice from people raised a
murderer
they don't make three other people on
earth until the quarter of the world's
population playing video games just
shake hands
I love sex love the old sex it's very
difficult 87 X was really into yoga and
choke sex I was like do you enjoy
breathing or it or not the next message
I do love the ladies I think they have
the sexiest gender and the human race
going in the top 72 conquered it I don't
think I could ever have sex with a man
sorry sir my contacts out like but it
sometimes because I'm inside the ladies
I've never loved had a beautiful woman
and been like man she's gorgeous but is
there a version of her that's bigger and
hairier and has less kindness too
pathetic
ladies I said I'm on a date with this
girl as she was like if I got into a
horrible car crash and I was disfigured
would you still want to date me I was
like well that's a good point really do
need improve highway safety for a part
of our infrastructure I think doing
drugs is awesome you know go on a date
do some drugs
I don't like sober people we're gonna
light it day to make you happy price
control back in your life I was talking
to this guy who was like oh man I'm such
a sex addict you wouldn't even know what
that's like yeah they made movies or
books or TV shows or songs about this
fortunately you know those sex addicts I
think they keep to themselves what are
you really thinking and always in the
corner of a party I my name is Hans Kim
that is my real name son a stage name I
was like how do we an audience's think
about North Korea and the Nazis like
perform
my parents taking Hans because they
didn't want kids at school to make fun
of me for having an Asian name I just
think that a comedy clubs and people
laugh I think I was meant to be a
comedian and it worked like a charm
that's the way under the radar there no
idea was Asian
they were playing parents it's hard
having a name like Hans and going to
Starbucks because they expect the
Scandinavian tourists to show up so I
started using a pseudonym I started
going by the name another salt my
marriage mother a human ding-dong
I have a hard time with sex
people call me a premature ejaculator
premature taboo I came at the perfect
time but I was doing amazing
there's maturity then I'm going to
exceed yourself trying to last longer
next time I love people go out for like
at the club's nowadays to go picking up
chicks which I don't do I like to stay
inside and check out pigs that's what I
do
I'll show you Photoshop women into
pictures that you're in under this big
chicks I am NOT a big pig people hate
that I don't say dick pics and farm okay
I'm telling you take movies now son
there's a word about lighting a word
about dialogue what is the motivation
behind this boner in case it started
having an agent penis everyone makes fun
of us which was my feelings because even
if we all have small penises which we
don't mind it's all I read here that I'm
Billy oh we got small dicks okay we'll
go find a new hobby bother you we
wouldn't just give up okay we start
study because that's what we do I'm
learning how to use it like sewing
machine I love the ladies but I try not
to stare at that because that's a crime
okay I think I feel like a women a women
a woman is like a beautiful sunset with
rights down inside we can call it calm
sign thanks he's not yours
I had a sex once but I had to pretend
like I was someone I wasn't to get laid
so I what's even the point of that
that's like my character got laid out in
bed like any nice I like I already know
more I could get laid I want to see this
angry asian boy could be rewarded with a
human
human please hi I wish I was rich rich
people after they have good sex turn to
each other I don't like man we were they
are missing out on anything
are we a whole breath of the human
experience at our fingertips put a light
for them I love being in Seattle because
I love being able to cut my window and
be like why should I try it when the
days not even trying
once we did your comms tonight I'd like
to say I'm from Washington State I'm
from Bellevue in the house four to five
four three five to 137 plays with these
house up to this [ __ ]
love love being propelled view because I
have the opposite of PTSD now I've been
Mexico like holy [ __ ] that kid has a gun
I read about this on Pais let's go talk
to it like a story whenever I meet
people I tell them I'm from Washington
State because I'm trying to
differentiate it from Washington DC but
because I'm money I'm proud that we
achieve statehood we did it guys suck on
that Porto Rico
in his territory gates this is Shady
Pines we fill out paperwork in
Washington State isn't it's a good state
to be a state of mind are you doing I'm
glad I could be performing like your
foot rest tonight what's working let's
take up as much space as possible
I feel like you don't like me know what
you want to water I don't know how to
talk to people I don't know why you know
people call me autistic whatever that's
the only disease that you diagnose as a
bar was ever like a man you talk like
you mesothelioma yeah I came from New
York which is a huge City they probably
heard of it I've been there a year now
and I'm accustomed myself to the New
York ways I think I'm a New Yorker now I
did the most New York thing yesterday
actually I
money and has a new phone I love The
Subways the subways are pretty cool
except but homeless people get on and
beg for change I feel like a captive
audience so what I usually do is I go
into the next car with the doors they
have it between the cars I just switch
the next part that way you can say noted
in over and over again sometimes hosters
two cars in front of him and do his
whole life before you guys say the heart
this time of the subway you know what
they say on the subway if you see
something suspicious say something
suspicious I saw an unattended package I
was like the better it penetrated
Saturday we're gonna burn it the whole
situation I wish there were more honest
on the subway now this is a problem
Bodie train the next stop will be middle
of this tunnel for no reason I feel like
people over one everyone to see English
need to use public transportation more
you really want everyone on this bus to
be able to communicate with you I want
to talk to you go away it's beaching
charm
sound like people I think it's weird
that people play immigrants for their
problems and like you know who's taking
all my money the only people with less
money than me
they've got my money with other people
with the money maybe they take your
money because they have it other people
the Liberals in Seattle I hear because
I'm tired of people understanding my
sarcasm afraid I don't like PC white
people and there's nothing that we don't
humans like talking to a customer
service agent I'm sorry you have that
experience a lot my manager know in the
natural I find it fascinating that
rednecks can adapt to any survival
situation that you put them in except a
situation where everyone has equal
rights kind of this about you can
survive in a swamp with an alligator why
can you survive in the cul-de-sac with a
minority are you trying to smiling
of course I'm for immigration because I
look like this I don't understand that
people were like whatever speak English
or get out of my country because they're
never like the people that want to have
a conversation with the foreigner never
like I don't speak English so I can
better get to know your culture this
language barriers kill Romania
understand a lot of the phrases in
English there's like kind of the phrase
don't drop the soap which is a very
thoughtful no because it should be if
you don't talk this hope you would still
get raped if you just hug let me clean
hands while it happens I thought of
these rape was like man I wanna get that
kid but he never know they're go-getters
I think it's crazy how people have post
nice now I do post nice it was just kind
of cold I'd like to deliver post mates
in my college so I share so that people
can see that the system isn't working
it's all gonna touch my chili Anna
please ten I so here's here's my
situation is my living situation I live
in New York I live in a van in New York
an automobile so I can pursue comedy
full-time so you didn't think I was
funny I'm sorry I'm trying my hardest I
literally don't know what more I could
do I'm operating at peak performance
[Music]
it's not very difficult because now it
puts a lot of pressure on my comedy
people are like yeah that was funny but
not living a car funny
Corinne I took an apartment buddy
the human was it's a weird experience
lavinia car like I woke up today and
almost like I wonder what the weather
outside is like I was like probably
exactly the same as the weather inside
this [ __ ] Park it's quite cold in
there and it makes it hard to date
because girls like it when you have a
shelter so even if a girl does want to
go home with me what usually happens is
we go for a drive it's old well I can
work up the courage to tell that we
arrived 45 minutes ago
I was just looking for a neighbor that
was more embarrassing than living in my
car yeah she's really having them in a
copper bracelet it's a toss-up really I
hate getting parking tickets have you
ever been taken on your home I started
taking a windshield wipers off my car
why keep an open line of communication
with son Devon says anything nice that
comes people haven't realized man I saw
this sorry driving that's had a 25 miles
per hour which children are present well
what if they're going in the past and
I'll pass my drive Society
all right well now you know that about
me so you can talk about that after the
show I give you I gave you a kernel of
information thank you guys so much you
guys are great I had a great time
I hope like him
[Applause]
[Applause]